Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Viviamo in un mondo
profondamente diseguale.
Ce lo raccontano, ogni anno,
i rapporti di Oxfam,
quando ci raccontano che, nel 2019,
le 26 persone più ricche del pianeta
detenevano la stessa ricchezza
della metà più povera del mondo:
3,8 miliardi di persone.
E in Italia, nello stesso anno,
il cinque percento
più ricco della popolazione
aveva una ricchezza superiore a quella
del 90% di popolazione più povero.
E non è tutto,
perché negli anni di pandemia
quei rapporti ci raccontano
come le dieci persone più ricche del mondo
abbiano visto più che raddoppiare
i loro patrimoni,
con un ritmo di 15.000 dollari al secondo,
mentre 163 milioni di persone
sono scivolate verso la povertà.
Le diseguaglianze erano
elevatissime già prima;
ma con la pandemia,
attraverso la pandemia si sono acuite,
affiancando nuovi bisogni
e anche nuove povertà.
E che cosa sono le diseguaglianze?
In quali forme si manifestano?
Ci sono diseguaglianze
sociali, economiche,
che si manifestano, ad esempio,
nelle differenze di reddito
e delle condizioni materiali;
ci sono diseguaglianze di accesso
ai servizi fondamentali,
come la sanità, come l'istruzione;
ci sono le diseguaglianze territoriali,
quelle di riconoscimento,
quelle di genere, quelle generazionali.
Ecco: si manifestano, ad esempio,
in una fortissima concentrazione
delle ricchezze in poche mani;
ma anche nella distanza abissale
tra le retribuzioni dei grandi manager,
paragonate a quelle
di lavoratrici e lavoratori
che invece si trovano alla base
di queste piramidi aziendali
sempre più appuntite.
Si manifestano in una concezione
patriarcale della famiglia
che vuole negare i diritti delle altre;
si manifestano con la
discriminazione dei migranti,
nella ricattabilità di chi non ha tutele.
Ma si manifestano, pure,
nelle barriere architettoniche
che incontrano le persone con disabilità.
O ancora, nei divari
salariali, o occupazionali,
che colpiscono le donne.
E anche nelle ingiustizie,
che ciclicamente si riproducono,
tra il Nord e il Sud del mondo.
E anche nella mancanza di voce, e di peso,
nei luoghi dove si decide.
Ecco: con queste diseguaglianze,
la società non può andare avanti.
Questa è una consapevolezza
che ormai hanno raggiunto, e condiviso,
anche le istituzioni economiche
internazionali, come l'OCSE.
Quindi non ci sono più scuse,
non possiamo più accettare
questo stato di cose.
La società si potrà rialzare
soltanto se riuscirà a tendere una mano
a chi oggi fa più fatica,
perché si possa emancipare
finalmente dal bisogno.
Emanciparsi dal bisogno,
perché se le stime della Banca Mondiale
ci raccontano che la metà
della popolazione
vive con circa cinque dollari
e mezzo al giorno,
ecco che in quello stesso giorno, invece,
i più ricchi guadagnano
circa due miliardi e mezzo.
Ecco, dobbiamo dire una cosa:
dobbiamo dire che è positivo,
ed è necessario,
che qualcuno crei valore
e che faccia profitto.
Qual è il problema?
È la mancanza di sistemi redistributivi,
che assicurino, anche,
che chi ha di più contribuisca
in proporzione maggiore
al benessere collettivo,
al benessere di tutta la società.
Perché un mondo così ingiusto
non è più sostenibile e non ha futuro.
Diseguaglianze che sono
legate strettamente
anche all'emergenza climatica,
perché chi oggi sta pagando più caro
il prezzo della crisi climatica in corso
sono i Paesi che hanno
meno contribuito a causarla.
Si parla poco della storia del lago Chad,
che era una risorsa
straordinaria, inestimabile,
incastonata tra quattro paesi africani
ai confini del Sahara.
E che nel giro di questi decenni,
a causa del riscaldamento globale,
si è sostanzialmente prosciugata,
costringendo migliaia
e migliaia di persone
alla povertà, oppure a doversi spostare.
Ecco: abbiamo molto a che fare con quello
che sta accadendo nel lago Chad.
Ma anche dentro i nostri confini,
chi paga di più il prezzo
della crisi climatica
è chi non può decidere
dove vivere, dove lavorare
e quale aria respirare mentre lavora.
Il caro energia, il caro delle bollette
colpisce tutte e tutti, è vero;
ma in una società così diseguale,
colpisce più duramente
le fasce di reddito più basse.
È difficile raccontare
le diseguaglianze per immagini,
ma se ce n'è una che mi ha colpito
è quella delle immagini degli incendi
che ci sono stati in California nel 2019.
E durante quei roghi,
abbiamo visto immagini
di lavoratrici e lavoratori domestici
che andavano comunque
verso il fuoco per lavorare,
mentre i ricchi proprietari
di quelle case evacuavano.
Sono persone per cui un giorno in meno
di una paga da fame
fa comunque la differenza
per essere in grado
di portare a casa un pasto.
Ecco, per questi motivi si è sviluppata,
e si è fatta largo, in questi anni,
una consapevolezza nuova,
soprattutto nelle mobilitazioni
intrecciate delle nuove generazioni,
che giustizia sociale e climatica
siano inscindibili.
E che bisogna, quindi, unire le lotte
per la conversione ecologica
e contro ogni forma di diseguaglianza
e di discriminazione.
E allora, la domanda che ci dobbiamo fare
è proprio questa:
si possono fare politiche
che insieme realizzino
la giustizia climatica e sociale?
Come scrisse Alexander Langer,
molto tempo fa,
"La conversione ecologica avverrà
quando apparirà socialmente desiderabile".
Come la rendiamo desiderabile?
Ecco: voglio fare alcuni esempi concreti
che chi ha potuto fare
amministrazione a tutti i livelli -
a me è capitato di farlo
a livello regionale -
può fare politiche
che attuano una differenza.
Lo può fare, ad esempio,
investendo nella riqualificazione
delle case popolari.
Perché vuol dire riuscire, ad un tempo,
ad abbassare le bollette
alla fascia di reddito più in difficoltà
e ad abbassare le emissioni climalteranti.
Vuol dire che si può fare, ad esempio,
incentivando la sostituzione
delle caldaie a metano
con dei sistemi a pompe di calore
che siano collegati a un'energia pulita
che si può fare attraverso
i pannelli fotovoltaici sui tetti.
Un sistema, quindi, che si autoalimenti.
Si possono fare politiche
di azzeramento dei costi
e di gratuità del trasporto
pubblico locale,
per i giovani che fanno parte
delle famiglie meno abbienti.
E si possono fare,
queste politiche di gratuità
del trasporto pubblico,
anche per le persone senza dimora,
perché anche loro
hanno diritto alla mobilità.
Ed è un modo per creare,
anche, una cultura,
una convenienza della scelta
del mezzo pubblico, e collettivo,
e meno inquinante
rispetto all'idea di prendere l'auto
per andare, ad esempio,
ogni giorno da casa a scuola.
Si possono fare politiche
come quelle che suggeriscono
le comunità energetiche.
Le comunità energetiche ci permettono,
permettono alle cittadine e ai cittadini,
alle associazioni,
ai comuni, alle imprese,
di mettersi insieme, di fare comunità
per autoprodurre e condividere
energia pulita e rinnovabile.
Di nuovo, una doppia convenienza:
abbasso le bollette,
ma al contempo abbasso le emissioni.
Ecco: abbiamo bisogno di queste scintille
di un modello diverso di società.
Ci danno speranza,
le dobbiamo rendere sistema.
Perché le diseguaglianze
sono così aumentate,
e il pianeta è arrivato così vicino
al punto di non ritorno,
non per un cinico gioco del caso,
ma per effetto di precise scelte,
per effetto di scelte che derivano
dal modello economico sociale
che ha imperato in questi anni:
il modello neoliberista.
Secondo cui le diseguaglianze
tutto sommato sono il prezzo da pagare
nell'illusione di una
crescita senza limiti,
che intanto bisogna fare quella
perché poi, automaticamente,
si redistribuirà.
Ma non è andata così:
anzi, è andata al contrario.
E la buona notizia è
che se sono state scelte a portarci qui,
per quanto sbagliate,
noi possiamo intraprendere scelte diverse;
ed è in questa direzione
che dobbiamo puntare.
"Libertà è partecipazione"
diceva una canzone, che nessuno di noi
ha dimenticato, di Giorgio Gaber:
ed è vero.
Non ci può essere libertà
senza partecipazione
alla propria comunità.
Però diciamoci, anche,
che per partecipare
bisogna essere in condizione di farlo.
Che libertà di partecipare ha
una lavoratrice, un lavoratore,
con un contratto precario,
con un salario da fame,
che non riesce ad arrivare
non solo alla fine del mese,
ma alla fine della settimana?
O se non ha avuto possibilità
di accesso all'istruzione
per potersi informare,
e per poter davvero contribuire
alla vita pubblica?
Ecco: quindi sì, libertà è partecipazione;
ma libertà è anche redistribuzione.
Redistribuzione di cosa?
Delle ricchezze, del potere,
del sapere e anche del tempo.
Redistribuzione del sapere:
che cosa significa?
Vuol dire un grande investimento,
a partire dai primi mesi di vita,
sull'educazione, sull'istruzione,
sull'università pubblica,
sulla ricerca pubblica.
Vuol dire investire sin dai primi mesi,
ad esempio, nell'educazione dell'infanzia.
Io vengo da una regione
dove si è fatto da tempo
un forte investimento sui nidi.
Perché?
Per tre ottime ragioni:
perché far partire prima
i percorsi educativi
delle bambine e dei bambini
li rende, secondo gli studi, più solidi.
Ma anche perché è il modo di contrastare
la povertà educativa
e la dispersione scolastica.
La seconda grande ragione
è perché è uno strumento
fondamentale di supporto
alla conciliazione
dei tempi di vita e di lavoro
all'interno delle famiglie;
e in questo è un modo di sostenere,
anche, l'occupazione femminile.
E la terza grande ragione
è che in questo modo,
investendo nelle infrastrutture sociali,
noi riusciamo a trasformare una parte
di quel lavoro di cura non pagato -
che grava sulle spalle delle donne,
soprattutto nelle famiglie -
in lavoro retribuito e qualificato
all'interno di un sistema di servizi.
Redistribuire il sapere, però,
vuol dire anche evitare
grandi concentrazioni di dati -
pensate al tema dei dati;
ma vuol dire anche sapere governare
l'innovazione tecnologica.
Perché ha facilitato le nostre vite,
ha facilitato i processi produttivi:
lo vediamo tutto intorno a noi.
Ma non dobbiamo accettare per forza
che, insieme a questa facilitazione,
porti antichissime forme
di sfruttamento del lavoro a cottimo,
come il caso dei rider.
E allora è anche l'occasione
per scrivere nuove tutele
del lavoro digitale,
del lavoro che sta
cambiando intorno a noi,
per evitare che questi
processi, non guidati,
polarizzino ulteriormente i divari
e acuiscano le diseguaglianze.
Redistribuire, poi, le ricchezze:
redistribuire le ricchezze
a partire dal fatto che non è accettabile
avere salari così bassi,
non è accettabile avere
un precariato così avanzato
che condiziona e ruba futuro,
soprattutto a giovani e donne.
Il 62% dei lavoratori e delle lavoratrici
under 24 in Italia, dato settembre 2022,
hanno dei contratti a termine.
Hanno dei contratti quindi precari,
che non permettono di costruire futuro.
E allora bisogna lottare
contro questa forma di precariato,
bisogna riuscire ad alzare i salari,
bisogna finalmente riuscire
a fissare un salario minimo,
sotto il quale si dica chiaramente
che non è nemmeno lavoro, è sfruttamento.
Ecco: si può agire sulle diseguaglianze
anche chiudendo quei divari
retributivi di genere
che ci raccontano che in Europa, oggi,
le donne, a parità di mansioni,
guadagnano ancora circa
il 14% meno degli uomini
come retribuzione media oraria.
E anche questo non è accettabile.
Ma se vogliamo, davvero,
redistribuire le ricchezze
con uno sguardo che non può
che essere europeo e globale,
allora vuol dire, anche,
che dobbiamo vedere l'elefante.
Dobbiamo vedere quante ricchezze
si nascondono nei paradisi fiscali.
Anche quelli senza palme,
anche quelli più vicini a noi.
Ma ci sarebbero politiche
che riescono, anche, a recuperare
parte di quelle somme.
Lo abbiamo visto dalle stime
che hanno fatto professori
come James Henry, di "Tax Justice",
che nel 2012 ha fatto una stima -
chiaramente di un fenomeno
che è difficile stimare, perché sommerso -
ma ha stimato
che nei paradisi fiscali di tutto il mondo
si nascondano 32.000 miliardi di dollari.
32.000 miliardi di dollari:
ecco, pensate a cosa
vuol dire questa cifra.
Sono l'equivalente
di 20 anni del PIL italiano!
Henry non è l'unico ad aver fatto
degli studi in questo tema.
Ci sono state inchieste
giornalistiche importanti:
LuxLeaks, Panama Papers, Paradise Papers.
Ma qualche anno dopo Richard Murphy,
un altro professore,
ha fatto un'altra stima interessante,
raccontando che solo in Europa
il mancato gettito fiscale
per gli Stati membri
potrebbe ammontare fino a circa
825 miliardi di euro ogni anno.
825 miliardi di euro!
Sono risorse sottratte
agli investimenti nel futuro,
nella ricerca, nell'innovazione,
nella conversione ecologica,
nella redistribuzione.
E si possono recuperare,
si devono recuperare.
Ne salterebbe fuori
un altro Next Generation EU,
su quella stessa cifra.
Dati impressionanti,
perché in questa corsa
al ribasso fiscale sfrenata,
anche tra gli Stati europei,
perdiamo tutti, Stati e cittadini;
e ci guadagna solo coloro che,
come tante multinazionali,
riescono sostanzialmente a ottenere
delle aliquote dello zero virgola.
Oppure, con grande creatività,
a inventare schemi pensionistici,
patent box, delle società fantasma,
dei trust, dei sistemi di scatole cinesi.
Ecco: però, anche qui,
delle politiche si possono fare
che vanno in una direzione diversa.
Politiche basate sulla trasparenza,
che non costano nemmeno tanto,
ad esempio per le imprese.
Voglio citare alcuni esempi concreti:
l'importanza dello scambio
automatico di informazioni,
da fare anche con i Paesi
in via di sviluppo,
che altrimenti non avrebbero la forza
per richiedere queste stesse informazioni.
C'è una politica, molto importante,
che si chiama CBCR.
CBCR vuol dire "Rendicontazione
Stato per Stato":
nel 2021, è stata approvata
a livello europeo
per chiedere a tutte le multinazionali
operative in Europa
di dirci quanti profitti fanno,
quante tasse pagano,
in ogni paese in cui operano.
Basterebbe questo,
basterebbe un po' di trasparenza
per far saltare molti
di questi meccanismi elusivi.
E lo dobbiamo fare coinvolgendo,
appunto, i paesi più poveri,
perché anche su questo versante
sono quelli che pagano più alto il prezzo.
Secondo alcuni dati dell'Unione Africana,
negli ultimi 50 anni
i Paesi dell'Unione Africana
avrebbero perso circa
mille miliardi di dollari,
tra evasione, elusione e corruzione.
Ed è più o meno
la stessa cifra, pensateci,
che hanno ricevuto in termini
di aiuti allo sviluppo.
Altro che aiutarli a casa loro,
come qualcuno dice:
noi stiamo togliendo con una mano
quello che diamo con l'altra.
Ecco: redistribuire anche il tempo.
Perché è tempo, veramente,
di liberare il tempo
di chi si occupa di cura
all'interno delle famiglie.
E un dato, anche qui
di Oxfam, interessante
ci dice che, se noi appaltassimo domattina
l'intero carico di cura
che grava sulle spalle delle donne
a una sola azienda,
quell'azienda avrebbe un fatturato
di 10.000 miliardi di dollari.
Vuol dire fare i congedi paritari,
come hanno iniziato a fare in Spagna,
pienamente retribuiti e non trasferibili
per entrambi i genitori;
addirittura la Finlandia sta provando
a renderli di cinque mesi,
mentre qui in Italia abbiamo
solo dieci giorni per i padri.
Ecco: fare passi avanti
vuol dire ridurre le diseguaglianze.
Fare passi avanti, anche,
sulle politiche per la casa.
La redistribuzione del potere
vuol dire partecipazione,
vuol dire ascolto,
vuol dire sapere
che noi chiudiamo i divari
se ascoltiamo territori e comunità diverse
e mettiamo in campo delle risposte
commisurate a quei bisogni diversi,
anche per non metterli
in contrapposizione,
in conflitto tra di loro.
È così che, quando abbiamo dovuto
aiutare tante famiglie
che non riuscivano a pagare l'affitto
durante la pandemia,
non abbiamo dato a tutte
e tutti la stessa cosa,
perché questo non riduce
le diseguaglianze.
Abbiamo provato a dare dei contributi
commisurati alle difficoltà diverse
che avevamo davanti.
Di lavoratori e lavoratrici
in cassa integrazione,
con una forte riduzione del loro reddito;
o di lavoratori e lavoratrici stagionali,
che di reddito in quei mesi
hanno avuto zero.
Ecco, se guardiamo
quelle diverse necessità,
e diamo risposte commisurate,
allora sì, questo è il grande ruolo
che dovrebbe avere la politica,
che dovrebbero svolgere le istituzioni:
riuscire a chiudere quei divari,
non certo ad alimentare
le tensioni sociali
che le diseguaglianze,
purtroppo, portano con sé.
Grazie.
(Applausi)